[Music]
a
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud proud proud and do not give
a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
you [__] eating [__] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the Tony
Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
[Music]
them well it sucks to suck doesn't
it oh Jim
[Music]
comr you're such a loser I I love how
yesterday the entire the entire
Republican
party was paused in the moment to watch
Joe Biden
presidency coming to a crash all the way
down into the ground and into a big
explosion as the new piece of evidence
that they produced was an email and the
email was immediately debunked and Byron
Donalds was made a fool even Steve
Bannon Steve Bannon does not like the
House Republicans
anymore they're
criticizing U the
work if you want to call it that the
work that the House Republicans did
yesterday okay so let's back up let's
rewind a bit about how why I was so
excited to watch a hearing yesterday
right why I was so excited to hear the
hearing yesterday the leadup to it and
the reason why is not not just because
of the moments that uh Jasmine Crockett
had which oh my God I can't wait to play
this clip she has a great [__] a
moment it's it's fantastic uh moscowitz
had Great Moments Rasin had Great
Moments uh let's see who else do oh AOC
had Great Moments there were so many
slam dunk
moments when it came to the Republicans
in the house
absolutely absolutely destroying
themselves and I knew that's what it
would be is just rake stepping right but
let's back up a bit let's talk about the
rake stepping and let's talk about why
this [__] happens with these fools so
much you would think they would learn
but the problem is is that they're not
serious
people and when you have nonserious
people in
Congress serious career staffers do not
go work for those unserious people let
me explain something to you a little bit
about how government and governance
works the representatives that you vote
for rather they're you know state
government or federal government
whichever it may be sometimes it could
be city council as well they have staffs
and the reason why those Representatives
have staffs is because that one person
couldn't do the work that that one
person needs to do to represent all of
their
constituents without a staff it just
wouldn't be possible right now to do
your job
well especially when you're in a
district where you have to do your job
well it's very important that you have a
very very good staff that not only is
very good at you know like I don't know
researching things making sure you're
whatever you're saying as the
representative is on the up and up and
it's correct in a way that you can
defend it right but
also also those staffers need to know
how government
works they need to know how Committee
hearing rules work they need to those
staffers need to give you Direction on
making sure you have everything you need
when you're going to make a big
political point with a hearing like they
did
because this is politics folks I I'm not
going to I'm not going to [__] you
here Democrats hold hearings for
political reasons so do Republicans this
happens inside our government whether it
be at Congress the senate or your state
your state level or even your county
level for that matter it it it's
politics so yeah it's going to be
[__] political how we don't
understand this is beyond me me but
maanga definitely does not know that
when you're going to have political
theater you want everyone to know their
lines and to know their blocking and you
want to make sure you have people behind
the scenes the stage staff if if we're
talking about
theater to make sure everyone has
everything just the way it needs to be
rather it's the set exactly the way it
needs to be the costumes the makeup the
lights the audience
is tuned in I mean all this [__]
matters but the problem is is that when
you have Jokers like Jim Jordan and
James comr and Jason Smith and list goes
on past that you have Matt gats Marjorie
Taylor green Lauren bobert Kevin
McCarthy when you have these people as
um who is going to be the people putting
on this show
right if you don't have a good staff
that show's going to be [__] have you
ever been to a theatrical performance
and you it's just like what what the
hell is happening why is everything
seeming to fall apart here at the show
the actors know their lines they're
appearing to be on stage when they need
to be but the lights aren't coming up
the curtains aren't coming on the sets
aren't changing the way they need
to H I wonder what it could be I wonder
if there's a whole stage crew that make
sure that the stage is
set they don't have serious staff that's
the problem why in the [__] if you were
a career staffer in Washington because
that's who those that's who generally
works as staff members in Washington is
career staffers now they they normally
you know when someone gets elected a
senator or congressperson they'll bring
along some of their campaign staff to be
on their permanent staff but generally
they start to staff out their offices
with
with career staffers or who are going to
become career staffers in Washington DC
and generally those people I don't know
make it their life's work to know how to
be a [__] staffer the problem is is
that a lot of people in Washington do
not want to work for these people
because they do not want it on their
resume that they staffed for [__] Jim
I don't report sex crimes Jordan Matt
gats Lauren bobert Marjorie Taylor green
or Jim comr they do not want on their
[__]
resume would you would you as a as a
person who wants to be a career
Republican staffer want to have that
that [__] nonsense when you're going
to look for a job to stay in Washington
DC would you no you wouldn't and this is
why they are so [__] derelict in
their Duty and it appears that they're
so unserious is because they can't
attract serious
people they can't I mean Byron Donald's
basically [__] face pled
yesterday anyone who ever takes Byron
Donald seriously ever again is a [__]
joke Byron Donald's just absolutely
destroyed his reputation in front of the
American people yesterday by submitting
a new piece of evidence that was going
to be the oh my God this is going to be
groundbreaking groundbreaking email that
no one has ever seen before where Hunter
Biden asked his uncle James to make sure
that Dad gave him money the problem is
is it was they were talking about
alimony they weren't talking about
foreign
payments Joe Biden would not agree to
pay Hunter Biden's alimony because
Hunter Biden
had wasted his
fortune and that's what the email was
about AOC absolutely destroys Byron
Donald's right there on the
spot the problem is is that these
Republican Nazis don't have any
shame and that's the reason why Byron
Donalds did what he did yesterday
because they don't have
shame and to believe to believe that
Byron Donalds was going was going to
submit this piece of
evidence in the hearing and not be
checked immediately only tells you how
[__] Brazen they
are it only tells you why Trump thinks
he's going to get away with everything
they really truly do believe that they
can lie to their base and that will get
them by because they're not again I I
want I want to be clear about this
they're not lying to us people who know
the [__] truth or who are willing to
to look at the evidence and go well
that's a [__]
lie they're not talking to
us that's not who they're propagating
to they have to keep their base engaged
with
Trump they have to it's their only
chance it's their only chance to win the
house it's their only chance to remain
uh uh any sort of relevancy in the
Senate which they're
irrelevant today speaking of the Senate
I would be derel in my duty if I didn't
bring up the fact that Senator the
California Senator Diane Feinstein
passed away this morning at the age of
90 I'm going to go through that today
and why that's probably important um to
our what's going on in Washington
DC but you
know yeah leave it to the mainstream
media I'm sure right now somewhere a
mainstream media person is writing a
headline if they're not if they're if
they're not listening to my show they're
probably writing a headline why Diane
Feinstein's death is bad for Joe
Biden I guar godamn toe you I guarantee
you there someone writing that [__]
right now there's already a person on on
it they're writing an article there's
probably three of them at the New York
Times four of them at the post writing
how Diane Feinstein's death hurts Joe
Biden I'm telling you that's what
they're gonna
do I mean all Joe Biden is out there
trying to do is defend democracy and
he's trying to make the choice Stark
which after his speech yesterday I think
he's getting U doing a better and better
job of it and I I want to thank I want
to
thank the Washington establishment DC
and the White House for um for tuning in
and listening of how important democracy
is and why it is so important to make
the choice in this country in this
election not about two people but about
the institution of our of our country
our constitution our nation our Liberty
our freedoms our rights and ultimately
our democracy our con stitutional
Republic as MAA always liked to to say
that it only is so if you get a chance
go listen to some of the speech
yesterday that Joe Biden gave um as he
was uh uh commemorating his his friend
Senator John McCain as they were giving
a library the name McCain yesterday but
it just it's kind of funny how Joe Biden
goes out to Arizona to give a a
speech uh to give a
library John McCain's name to put John
McCain's name on it and um he talks
about
democracy it's it's a [__] it's it's
wild that we're in this timeline that
this even exists that somehow it's you
know because the right-wing is going to
be really [__] pissed off because he
named Trump by name uh which is a a huge
step in in Joe Biden's rhetoric which it
should get more pointed towards Trump in
my opinion they should really throw
punches at him hard and throw punches at
his authoritarianism hard and one way to
do that is this government shutdown
that's I don't know about to happen
today well over the weekend when we come
're they're going to shut down the
government over the weekend it's gonna
happen don't let anyone fool you about
this Senate bill that they don't have
the votes uh in the house in the
Republican caucus now they have the
votes Kevin McCarthy could bring the
votes all he'd have to do say go to
hakee Jeff and ask Hakeem Jeff to give
him enough Democrats to get the votes
and they can keep the government open
but Kevin McCarthy can't do that and the
reason why is because of
authoritarianism did you know that did
you know the reason why our government
can't function is because we already
have a strain of authoritarianism here
in this
country it is the H the House of
Representatives is a good example of
what will happen if you reelect Trump
it's a good example now it's not perfect
right like because they only have
control of so much
[__] but who who do you think is
controlling the H the House of
Representatives besides Donald Trump
Kevin McCarthy isn't the
speaker I mean he he sits in the office
right and he's got the little
plaque but his balls reside in a Big Mac
Box down at Mar Lago or in Bedminster
wherever that wherever that fat [__] is
staying so that he he can pretend he's
not actually living at Mar Lago because
he can't actually live full-time at Mar
Lago soon he won't be able to live
fulltime anywhere because tis James is
going to confiscate all his
[__] but this is a perfect example of
what authoritarianism does in our
country Trump is dictating to the House
of
Representatives that he wants the
government shut down and the reason why
is very simple he
believes he believes that if he shuts
down the government he has a better
chance of not being
prosecuted period that's what he
believes now he believes his own [__]
[__] I mean for sure because it's
not necessarily going to stop him from
being prosecuted it may slow down a few
of the processes right like apparently
there's a Civil Trial that he's supposed
to testify in soon and it appears that a
government shutdown is probably going to
delay that
process because it's not essential that
that civil testimony be
taken so going to delay that process so
if you if you believe to any degree that
this shutdown is anything other than the
dictator Trump of manga telling Kevin
McCarthy that he has to shut down the
government then you're out of your mind
now Kevin mcarthy wants to do everything
he can do to keep the government open
because Kevin McCarthy knows that the
only way he can remain
speaker is to keep the government open
and the only way he can remain speaker
is to keep the is to close the
government he's in a real tough spot
here because he sold his soul to the
devil and because he traded away his
speakership to the authoritarian
Trump that's what's Happening Here what
what do you think the house [__]
hearing was
yesterday the the absolute [__] face
plant of the Republicans in the
house and and and it's wild it's wild to
watch right Wingers they're like oh they
totally [__] it up like what
they totally [__] it up what what are
you talking about what of course they
totally [__] it up you didn't see that
coming how are you so
mad that the Republicans in the House of
Representatives [__] up the hearing
yeah they were always gonna [__] it up
they're like oh they just didn't bring
the facts they didn't bring the evidence
to the Forefront as fast as they that's
because they don't have
it they don't have it now I mean again
the reason why the right-wingers like
Steve Bannon and other commentators are
telling their audiences this is because
yesterday was not a show of Republicans
giving America the reason why they're
GNA impeach Joe
Biden yesterday was an experiment in how
how Joe Biden is going to fight
back okay that's one thing that you
should take away as optimistic as you
can about that hearing yesterday
yester is that is that Democrats are
ready to [__]
fight and they're going to fight just as
hard as Republicans do with lies with
the truth they're gonna pile truth on
top of these son of a
[__] and we should be doing the same
and honestly we should be yelling and
screaming and adding in more curse words
than what Jasmine Crockett could even um
pepper in
there I love the [__] out of her Jasmine
Crockett you know that oh man I'm gonna
show you this clip for her and really
you know she she's she's very good at
what she does she's very good at giving
her take on what's going on she's very
passionate in those hearings she's not
[__] she's not boring she's not
reading off some [__] script
somewhere that some dummy wrote her
she's real she's authentic and she gives
no [__] not [__] one [__] left to
give with these some [__] and the
best part about it is she's a strong
black woman and they [__] hate that
oh my God they [__] hate that and it
makes me love her even more even more I
love Jasmine
Crockett and frankly I hope that she
stays in that United States house and
she stays in those committee hearings
absolutely torching those dumb bastards
every single [__] time she can and
I'm going to show you how she does it
it's it's [__] incredible I'm going
to show you how AOC absolutely dunks
Byron Donald's in the trash um but we're
we we're at a place in time where the
optimism should be that Democrats are
willing to fight for our [__] country
because really that's the problem
yesterday is that there is only one
person that that hearing was for
yesterday and it was Donald Trump and
the only reason why they had that
hearing I've been saying it for a long
time and the media start to pick up on
it I don't know who's listening if
you're listening out there you might
want to you know take some [__]
notes I it appears that you aren't but
there's only one reason for the Joe
Biden impeachment in the first place
pretending that they're going to impeach
him is because Donald Trump is a [__]
criminal he's a [__] crook he's a
goddamn treasonous piece of [__] and the
only way that they're going to gain any
kind of ground in votes in the general
election against Joe Biden is for Donald
Trump to stand on stage and say yeah I
might be criminally charged but Joe
Biden's just as big of a criminal so
that his brainless cult can go out and
say you know what that that Trump he
might you know he might have 91 Fones
charged against him and he might be out
on bail in four different jurisdictions
but man that Joe Biden's just as big of
a c criminal and that's what the stupid
email was about yesterday because they
have no proof no proof whatsoever that
Joe Biden has taken any money anywhere
that could be caused him to be impeached
and even if he did take money in 2017
which there's no evidence of it anywhere
that probably wouldn't justify him being
impeached in the first place because he
wasn't the vice president he wasn't
running for president so get the [__]
out of here with this
nonsense and honestly if we can't charge
Jared Kushner for taking two billion
dollar from the Saudis in a in a hedge
fund when he's not a hedge fund manager
the day the day the hedge fund he
started get this did you know this fact
Jared Kushner started a hedge fund the
day the day he left the day after he
left the wine house and the Saudis gave
it2 billion if we can't charge that
[__] and investigate that
[__] for that then stop talking
about Hunter Biden's dick
stop it's enough of this nonsense but
you know what if they want to keep going
let them keep going because we should
not take the shovel out of their hands
when they're digging their political
grave and I'm telling
yesterday it was a [__] Master Class
of what is going to happen next year in
the general election
folks just think of yesterday is
practice right it was just
practice on how to beat the ever loving
[__] out of these Ling ass Republican
Nazis all around the country next year
come the general election it was a
[__] masterclass practice of what
that is about to come and I you know I
got I get pushed back a little bit for
people like Tony you're way too
optimistic stop saying that the media is
is that Trump can't win folks he can't
win if we
engage he won't win if we do our [__]
job like we did in
2020 we just have to do our job in the
Democracy that is the optimism there we
do not have to be pessimistic about the
results of the election let's get fired
the [__] up let's stay [__] pissed
where we should stay pissed and let's
get in the fight like the Democrats were
in the fight yesterday that's the most
important thing not to sit back and act
like we're gonna [__] lose are that
we can lose [__] that [__] we are going
to beat the pants off these
[__] do you think do you think
the Allied Forces in the 1940s when they
finally arrived in Germany were like
well you know what I mean it's a
possibility that Hitler could still win
no they pushed and pushed and pushed and
they won they won that war against those
Nazis
then and it was a hot War but this war
is a war of
information and in a war of information
you don't [__] tell people lies and
you don't tell people what is real and
what isn't real and the real reality is
is this the Democrats know where these
votes are they know where we're going to
win and we have to do the work to get
there yeah it's going to be a it's going
to be a hard long hard SLO like we can't
just [__] stop fighting we can't just
stop working it's now time to dig in and
beat these [__] at The Ballot
Box every state every County every
Precinct it's time that we have optimism
it's time that we believe in our [__]
system it's time that we [__] believe
in democracy not this [__]
pessimistic [__] that somehow he's
got a chance of winning that's all
[__] nonsense if we do what we're
supposed to do he'll get [__]
trounced
period
period just like last year there was
supposed to be a big red wave oh oh man
the polls say a big red wave and if you
want to know the honest truth oh man
well that's just the media trying to
convince people to get out there and
vote you know what if the media wouldn't
have been selling that [__] nonsense
selling that [__] that [__] line
there was no [__] Red Wave no one
likes these [__] do you know
what would have happened Hakeem Jeff
would be be the Speaker of the
House Garren godamn
ti so stop with the [__] I don't
need to be told that we have to that we
have to pretend like Trump can win or
Trump's popular some [__] to win [__]
that [__] that's all [__] [__]
again last in
2022 during those midterms if the if the
[__] media would have been selling a
bunch of people the goddamn stupid ass
rigged up polls that show that there was
a red wave when there wasn't we would
have [__] won the house folks period
do you know how close it was get the
[__] out of here Lauren bobert wouldn't
be a congresswoman probably we're
talking less than 500
votes don't tell me don't tell me to not
to tell my
audience that that Trump can't win he
can't win if we do our job
it's our [__] country it's our
democracy it's our government it's our
ballot fight for it act like you're
gonna fight for it and put on your
[__] boxing gloves and get in that
boxing ring and throw the [__]
punches it's time it's
time not to [__] not to [__] act
like somehow he can beat us he can't
beat us are you kidding me little manga
cult 10 12% of the country there ain't
enough of them to beat us Time After
Time After Time they take a try to take
rights away from people try to ban
Women's Health Care in red States Kansas
Kentucky Montana Michigan now Ohio 22
times the Republicans have trying to
take away the rights of women to have
health care and people said not just no
but [__] no [__] you keep your [__]
hands off our rights and when people get
out there and do the work and you
believe in your [__] democracy and
you know you're GNA win because you have
the people behind you you will [__]
win every last time and we will trounce
Donald Trump and we will trout SMA we
will win back the house we will win
gains in the Senate and we will win in
States
period don't tell me to be no [__]
pessimist it ain't going to happen I'll
be pissed yell and scream I'll call out
the [__] and I'll show it to you why
you should be pissed and why you
shouldn't stay engaged here in this
[__] show you can goddamn guarantee
that there ain't going to be a day that
that message doesn't just sound
resoundingly so stay in the comments and
stay mad at me just stay mad at me do it
I Dare You doubt me doubt me because
optimism of democracy will get people
engaged and engagement will make sure
that our democracy lives on for another
election and we will move to the next
one to be the most important election of
our democracy's lifetime you can G damn
better guarantee that [__] don't go
anywhere we'll be right back right after
this what the [__] is wrong with you
people it's a rhetorical question at
[Music]
best we'll be right back on the Tony
Michaels
podcast
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only $50 a day
you can help us help those true
Americans recover from Biden's socialist
reign of terror these are those Trump
supporters and and this is that moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president Donald J Trump it's only $50 a
day recurring and it means you'll get
these Trump supporters the critical help
they so desperately need to survive
under this false regime please donate
now because those Trump supporters you
just saw can't wait another
moment [__] them [__] them [__] them
[__] them welcome wel we're back to the
Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast God damn this microphone's on
fire it's hot today isn't it son
[__] baby who baby who baby someone
accused me of being a grifter yesterday
too then I'm part of the grift oh boy
boy Tony gets his audience all fired up
he fear-mongers well have that for
fear-mongering why don't
you if that's fear-mongering then you
don't know what fear-mongering is just
because you know the threat of fascism
and just because you're pointing out the
threat of fascism and you go hey we need
to fight that and we need to fight that
with our democracy to defend it that's
not fearmongering but you know what
let's do a little bit of grifting as the
people think that I'm
grifting oh Tony
Tony oh my God you don't have any
corporate sponsors and you got to have
your your folks donate to you well yeah
how the hell do you think we keep this
microphone on do you think George Soros
actually sends me checks is that what
you
think he doesn't send me any I wish I
wish I was VC ramaswami and got George
Soros scholarships I really do I really
do I would take a George Soros check no
[__] way and I would tell you I'd
show you the check if he's in it you
know I'm completely honest completely
authentic and I don't hide anything here
at the Tony Michaels podcast I would
100% I would probably post that [__] on
social media to be quite honest if that
some [__] sent me a check I'd be like
look at this George Soros finally came
through he [__] sent me a
check I don't get Sor checks I wish I
did though really honestly George if
you're if you're you know going to pass
out a couple of them this month I I'll
take one that would be great that would
be that would be
great oh [__] there's no such thing as
George Soros chicks it just doesn't
exist I mean and if they do I've never
been told about them they're cutting me
out
because probably the wild [__] I say but
if you want to keep this microphone on
which you're the shareholders here at
the show you're the shareholders at D
Tony Michaels podcast without you I
could not keep this microphone on what
you should do is go to the Tony Michaels
podcast you can find everything right
there at the at the the URL the Tony
michaels.com it's right there on the
screen all the time the Tony
michaels.com you can find all of them
there if you want to send me a vinmo
chat you can do that I'll get it up on
screen as we go along if you want to buy
me Shots because you know I like joerger
buy some shots so Robert send in a vinmo
chat as we're speaking let me pull that
up on screen see this is what I'm
talking about this is the Griff those oh
no that's the wrong one this is the
Griff those folks are talking about
they're like look Tony Tony asked for
people to support him well how do you
think we keep this show going man love
your passion Tony no socials to plug
keep up the great work thank you Robert
very much for supporting the show
without you the audience I could not
keep this microphone on and it's not
just about money I that's not all the
grift is the grift here at the Tony
Michaels podcast is everyone tuning in
every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
on YouTube uh you subscribe to YouTube
or twitch or Facebook um twitch there's
a lot of people viewing over on Twitch
right now there's a lot of people on
Facebook uh if you want to support on
Twitch if you want to support the grift
here at the Tony Michaels
podcast I like saying that I think
that's where I'm gonna go with it from
now on if you want to support the grift
here at the Tony Michaels podcast go
over to Twitch
you can you can link your Amazon Prime
account to your Twitch account and you
can give us that one free subscription
you get with Amazon Prime and you know
that gives us a couple bucks of Amazon's
money each month if you want to do that
just go to the Tony mol.com the links
right there on how to do that and then I
figured out Facebook for all you listen
on Facebook I know a lot of people
listen on Facebook for some reason I got
the ability to do stars I didn't know
what starss were I had no idea
Facebook's like hey you want to do stars
I'm like what the [__] are Stars so I I
enabled Stars so apparently you can give
me stars over on um over on Twitch I
believe it's called cheering on Facebook
it's called Stars so if you want to give
your support that way any way you want
to give your support go ahead if you
want to buy me a shot if you want to do
a vinmo chat again I'll bring it up on
screen and if you want to buy merch but
mainly the thing that I need you to do
to support the show is to engage to
share the links to tell your friends
about the show tell them the rush liin
ball the left he's a crazy son [__] and
he says the f word a lot you should go
listen to him I mean that's yeah it's
kind of the the bare minimum there I
guess so again thank you Robert for your
vinmo chat oh my god did you see this CL
let's see what do we got for today as
far as bonehead of the week we got
bonehead of the week now let me check in
with Gabe Sanchez here I haven't heard
from him this morning uh week at top we
got to got to communicate here I just
literally just text him during the show
that's me me and Gabe don't talk on the
phone a lot believe it or not we text
most of the time um that's how we
communicate so we'll get bone end of the
week going for you uh today you guys you
guys um know that if you want to vote
for bonehead of the week you follow the
YouTube channel you vote on the YouTube
channel in the poll there just go to the
Tony Michaels podcast on YouTube vote
there or you can vote in the Discord now
I took the poll off Twitter because you
know [__] El Lon him and his [__]
backwards cowboy hat did you see
this Elon Musk doesn't know how to wear
a cowboy hat are you [__] [__] me
I think he did it intentionally don't
you come on he didn't I think I think he
did it
intentionally so that everyone would be
like it's backwards dude like when he
posted it on Twitter everyone be like
it's backwards
dude you know get more engagement
but he doesn't know how to wear a cowboy
hat but if you want to get on the
Discord you want to vote for Bon head of
the week I just I just stuck the uh the
Discord Link in the chat there you guys
can go take a you guys can go go over to
the U the Discord also great
conversation this morning fantastic
conversation this morning I had with all
the people who showed up for the
pre-show you guys know I do a pre-show
it's it's patreon only but you can join
patreon in the $20 tier or higher and
you can come to the Discord and get in
on the conversation with us in the
pre-show and it's every Monday and every
Friday an hour before the show we had a
great conversation this morning now
honestly that last 20 minutes I wasn't
even talking it was everyone was on
stage talking to each other they having
a great conversation uh I want to thank
Benny Benny's out there Benny uh he he's
in Germany he's been a he's been a
watcher of the show for quite some time
now he said some great words great kind
words giving me great encouragement and
that's the kind of stuff that keeps me
going here every single weekday for that
30 minute rant getting in doing the job
that we need to have done for our
democracy because it's not just about my
one microphone it's about all your
microphones every single one of you
every single one of you have a
microphone whether you know it or not
you really truly do I only have one
microphone and I speak to you but you
you out there can go speak to whoever is
in your universe so just remember that
that you matter you're you matter no
matter where you are in the world even
because Benny was giving us every reason
why it is so important for democracy to
survive here in the United States it's
important it's important all around the
world we We Are The Shining City on the
hill we are the the original liberal
democracy we are the strength that the
world looks to and turns to when you
talk about democracy and Joe Biden
really delivered that message last
yesterday of why we have to head off the
threat and that's really the most
important thing I mean yeah we got a lot
of problems to solve in this country
right I mean we see the UAW striking
because they're just not getting their
Fair wage they're not getting their fair
share at the big three the writer strike
is coming to an end it looks like sag
may come to an end soon after that now
we have the UPS workers really really
get um their fair
share of what they were of what they
deserve and we should have people all
around the country even if they're not
in unions getting their fair share and
we should push and push and push we
should also push so people don't go
broke because of a medical
bill I mean we want people to have
decent [__] wages not go broke
because of a medical bill I want people
to be educated in this country without
having to mortgage their entire lives
away for education in this country I
mean all the I think I think people I
think people's children should start
school at three instead of five not just
for the not just for to free up the
parents to go work and make that decent
wage but to also educate the educate the
new generation as soon as we possibly
can it's going to be super important to
stay competitive in this world I think I
think what we should do is bring back
more jobs to this
country and I think we can do that but
we can't do it without democracy we
can't we won't if you think the
authoritarian ism is the way to get
there oh my God you're in big [__]
trouble because that's the thing the
Republicans have truly yesterday was a
good example of how the Republicans has
given up on the truth and democracy they
just given up on it altogether they're
really all in for authoritarianism they
love it I mean they're operating as an
authoritarian party right like there's
one person he's not even elected or in
power and he has all the power over them
he controls the highest elected official
in their party he crowned him speaker
and he controls him and he controls the
people in the [__]
Congress and authoritarian figure
controls the House of Representatives
it's [__] gross it's [__]
disgusting it's why it's so
dysfunctional it's why it's why they're
going to fail ultimately because
authoritarian sucks that [__] sucks
that's the easy way out that's the easy
way out you don't want you don't want to
do the hard work of democracy and
compromise make sure you get to a place
that progresses Society to a better spot
more diverse more more Equity more
equality you don't want to do that hard
work you just want to do the simple
thing of letting some dumb [__]
telling you what to do what to think how
to dress what religion to believe that's
what you want you want to be a [__]
sheep well fine by me I'm not going down
that
road now I'm not gen reflecting to no
[__] authoritarian not going to
happen it's time we get real and know
our
choice our choice is either democracy
functional democracy or this
dysfunctional authoritarianism that we
have in the House of Representatives
right now let me show you a clip
yesterday oh my God she's one of my
favorite this you know I show a lot of
Jamie Rasin Clips yesterday and they
were fantastic oh my God they were
fantastic um but moscowitz he had some
great ones oh my God he really burnt
their house down um but this one clip in
particular um because there was Garcia
really went after them he had some great
moments but this clip with Jasmine
Crockett she is after my heart I tell
you what now here's why I like this clip
so much because it's her because they
[__] hate her oh my God they [__]
hate her and she's so [__] smart and
she's so [__] good at this oh my God
Jasmine come on the show let's do like a
[__] rant back and forth it'll be
fantastic but here's the thing I like
about this clip because I'll be out with
my friends you know like out at a
restaurant or something it's like a new
restaurant I've never been there right I
don't know I don't know where the
[__] restroom is and I'll ask the
table Where's the restroom but I use a
different word when I refer to the
restroom I don't call it a restroom I
don't call it a bathroom it's just not
what we call it when I was a
kid it's just not but let me show you
what Jasmine Crockett calls it here and
then you'll know what I call it listen
to this President of the United States
has committed but when we start talking
about things that look like evidence
they want to act like they blind they
don't know what this is these are our
national Secrets looks like in the
[__] to
me it looks like the national secrets in
the [__] to me that's right that's
what I call it oh my friends they get
all kinds of cringey when we're out like
you know we'll be at a restaurant and
there's a bunch of us and I'm like
where's the [__] I've never been here
where's the [__] and they're like
Jesus [__] Christ can't you call it
the bathroom I'm like no because it's
the [__] I mean I don't have to take
every time I go to the [__] I don't
have to take a [__] but that's where you
take a [__] so it's called the [__]
that's what it is it's the [__] and I
when I heard this clip I'm like oh my
God she is so great she's she is so she
is oh my God she is their [__]
Kryptonite isn't she and when she said
[__] I'm like no that's it I am now
100% a Jasmine Crockett fan um I'm a a
groupy whatever it takes you know they
swifties but I'm a I'm a Crockett I'm a
Crockett here on out there's no way that
I can't but let's let her finish up
because she goes on and on and on here
let's
listen this looks like more evidence of
our national Secrets say on a stage at
maril Lago we when we're talking about
somebody that's committed High crimes
it's at least indictments let's say 32
counts related to unauthorized retention
of National Security Secrets seven
counts related to obstructing the
investigation three false statements one
count of conspiracy to Def the United
States falsifying business records
conspiracy to Def fraud the United
States two counts related to efforts to
obstruct the vote certification
proceedings one count of conspiracy to
violate civil rights 23 counts related
to forgery or false document statements
eight counts related to soliciting and I
could go on because he's got 91 counts
pended right now but I will tell you
what the president has been guilty of he
is UN fortunately been guilty of loving
his child unconditionally and that is
the only evidence that they have brought
forward and honestly I hope and pray
that my parents love me half as much as
he loves his child until they find some
evidence we need to get back to the
people's work which means keeping this
government open so that people don't go
hungry in the streets of the United
States and I will
yield woo God damn alls I was expecting
at the end was [__] them [__] them [__]
them before she would yield back but of
course um she has a littleit little bit
more decorum than I would
have I I don't even know how I continue
with the show
here I I don't I don't even know how I
continue with the show here after that
maybe I should have waited till the very
end to show the Jasmine
Crockett now now the right- Wingers uh
this caught them in a whirlwind
yesterday this Jasmine this Jasmine CR
rocket clip and they're really upset
about
AOC but AOC doesn't quite bring that
attitude quite like Jasmine Crockett
does she does a wonderful job and she
really dunked uh Byron Donalds in the
trash
yesterday but the right-wing media
they're really pissed off and one reason
why is because the rasing clips the
moscowitz clips the Crockett Clips the
Garcia Clips on and on it went Goldman
on and on it went for Democrats to
smash the dummy the
bonehead Jim qanon comr but let's listen
to some of these clips in the right-wing
media the trader TV news networks as it
were why they think the House
Republicans blew their wad okay you know
what's amazing about this look this is
an impeachment inquiry all right you
don't blow the wad or the Wht at the
inquiry okay what you do is you wait
till the trial you don't allow anybody
to be impeached or cross-examined you
just present the minimal amount of
evidence you need to
look so here box wine is trying trying
to defend them um and the reason why
he's trying reason why she's trying to
defend them is because some of the
biggest voices out there including
including Steve Bannon let me show you
this um is very [__] pissed off that
the Republicans are very bad at
everything let's listen we have to have
a standard of how serious this is and
let me and I haven't been able to follow
the entire
thing but when the professor one the
professor's there it gives the opening
dialogue and he's got some nice things
he's laying out and he's impeachable and
then Raskin right on his
cross right on his
cross gets and I think I heard this
correctly well have you seen impeachable
offenses no have is this worse than
Trump on January 6 no that's maybe not a
witness I call initially to lay out the
case maybe my staff should have gone
through and asked questions like that in
making sure in the traditional
preparation of the witnesses oh oh see
even Steve Bannon this [__] Nazi
Traer even this [__] fascist piece of
trash understands what I I'm saying that
the staff is a bunch of [__] idiots
so when you got a bunch of [__]
idiots as Congress people and they're
hiring staff that's a bunch of [__]
idiots your outcome is looking like a
bunch of [__] idiots it's not
complicated to understand this [__]
especially when you have the biggest
[__] idiot of all
time directing this [__] to happen
Donald Trump of course this [__] is not
going to turn out well it's going to
look like a [__] mess do you remember
when that [__] took office you
remember when that [__] took office
everyone was questioning his businesses
and if he was going to die best do you
remember that [__] and he stacked a
whole table full of [__] blank ass
paper do you remember that I could go
back and show you the clip of the
picture that son of a [__] stacked up
blank ass paper on a table and tried to
convince America that that [__] had
words on it and that he was going to
divest in his businesses and that
described how it divest in his
businesses and when everyone found out
that was blank paper they weren't
[__] surprised that it was all
[__] fraud just like no one is
[__]
surprised that the Republicans had no
evidence yesterday not only did they
have no evidence the key witness
Jonathan Turley which I don't even
understand why he's a key witness in
this case what the [__] does Jonathan
Turley have anything to do with this
other than he's always on Fox News
giving fellacio to Donald Trump and the
Republicans just assume just assume he
was going to do that yesterday they just
made the Assumption they didn't prep
their witness at all folks not at all
because they thought Jonathan Turley
would sit there and say the [__] they
needed him to say that's it they believe
that and when he didn't say it it
[__] went
haywire and that's why the right-wingers
are pissed you haven't seen this guy in
a while look at this guy Patel holy [__]
this guy looks awful he looks worse than
Donald Trump Jr if you want to know the
honest truth this [__] rat yeah
that's right cash Patel is a
rat you want to know someone who's
flipped on Trump in in a federal in a
and got a deal with Federal prosecutors
I guar godamn toe you it's this guy this
guy totally flipped on Trump in the
documents case 100% full stop butash
Mattel's even pissed off he goes on on
on Trader TV News Network do you see
this he's in Las Vegas is that where
he's from I don't
know I don't know where this guy's from
but anyways I know where he needs to go
but I don't know where he's from but
let's listen to how cash is all pissed
off you Republicans are more worried
about getting your 30 second headline on
mainstream media and being glorified in
your little caucus circles on Capitol
Hill oh cash you dumb [__] you
think these Republicans were looking for
their 30second moment on May mainstream
media you pe you you dumb [__]
are just absolutely out to
lunch you are just out to lunch so now
what they're gonna do is they're gonna
sell James comr and Jim Jordan as
somehow part of the deep State and the
media conspiracy to convince you MAA
supporters I mean that's who he's
talking to right because he's talking on
Trader TV News Network think about this
who he's talking to think about the
audience that he's talking to so what he
trying what they're trying to do is spin
this now that the reason why James Gomer
and the reason why Jim I don't report
sex crimes Jordan and Jason Smith that
[__] just destroyed the chance to
impeach Joe Biden is because they're
part of the media and deep State con
conspiracy okay yeah just the same way
David Weiss the United States Attorney
Who was appointed by Donald Trump to
investigate Hunter Biden is somehow part
of the deep State because he's only
charging Hunter Biden with three gun
charges get the [__] out of here with
this nonsense
how stupid do these people think their
supporters are well they think they're
really [__] stupid listen then doing
the damn job for the American people and
that's what you saw today you got your
butts kicked by AOC she's in her 20s you
got your butts kicked by a former
bartender you got your butts handed to
you by the Democratic Cong congregation
and the mainstream
media did you hear that did you hear how
he just talked down to someone in their
20s who were a bar who was a bartender
well let me ask the audience here I
don't know if you were a bartender or
not but have you ever taken a job that
was similar to like a bartender like a
retail job or I I don't know a cook
maybe a server at a restaurant maybe a
buser at a restaurant you know what I
mean a greeter at a restaurant like a
host or a Hostess have have you ever
taken a job like that well cash Patel
thinks that you're a worthless piece of
[__] see do you understand why I yelled
and screamed the other day about [__]
unions and how these [__] [__]
and how Republicans look down upon the
working class in this
country can you imagine can you imagine
the majority of people who listen to
this show are probably people who live
on [__] Social Security and only
Social Security because they worked in
Industries like I don't know
bartending what a [__] what a [__]
piece of trash ladder pulling piece of
[__] garbage cash Patel is you
[__] talking down to American
people like as if a bartender isn't a
hard job H have any of you tended bar
tending bar is not an easy [__] job
my friend cash it's it's definitely not
as easy to try to help a former [__]
president steal documents but you know I
digress from that and you set it up for
them and you're in the majority I'm
sorry I may be talking down to some of
my friends over there but you had the
opportunity to make your case
and I'm still waiting for it oh that's
because you dummy there's no case to be
made these people always get gets so
[__] close to the truth don't they oh
man cash Matel gets right up to the
truth almost so much so the smacks face
right into it right just right up to the
truth and he can't he can't [__]
bring himself to say it out
loud but he thinks he's talking down to
Republicans he thinks he's talking down
to Jim comr and Jim I don't report sex
crimes Jordan that's who he thinks he's
talking down to he's talking down to the
people watching him when he's saying
[__] like oh she's in her 20s and she's
a former
bartender she tended bar to [__] work
her way through college you piece of
[__] W don't [__] people know that
you may not agree with everything AOC
says which I don't agree with everything
AOC says I don't agree with everything
AOC does that's not the intent I'm not I
don't have to agree with her to
understand why the [__] she is who she
is and why the hell New Yorkers elect
elect her and want her to be their
representative because she's one of them
it's the same stupid ass [__] logic
that John fedman isn't a good Senator
because he wears a hoodie Pennsylvania
elected John fedman who who wears
hoodies to be the lieutenant governor
and to be the United States senator they
expect him to be
authentic you [__] boneheads Jesus
Christ how can't these people muster up
enough courage to understand how just
human nature works it's really [__]
weird [__] it's really weird stuff you
know that's how it's going to go in
today's world with these Republicans all
right so let's go uh to a couple CLE
more Clips here because I want to show
you um I want to show
you Neil kabudo had a little bit
different take on it he wasn't mad at
Republicans he was just a little [__]
confused now this is on Fox News Neil
Cavuto is a host and has been a host on
Fox news for many many years and he was
on Fox Business Neil Cavuto in the
conservative world is known as sort of
someone who kind of like a Brett Bear
right or Chris Wallace some of these
kind of you know straight down the line
kind of thing and I can't believe he
said this to a Fox News audience but
listen to this this is [__] fantastic
thank you Neil Kabuto all right for the
better part of six hours uh I have been
following these hearings save an hour
off to do my Fox Business show earlier
today uh I don't know what was achieved
over these last six plus hours welcome
everybody I I know what was achieved
over the last six plus hours the
Republicans made absolute [__] fools
of themselves and made the country know
that there is none not a shred of
[__] evidence not one piece of
evidence that ties Joe Biden to any
payment that Hunter Biden made not only
that there's not run shred of evidence
that any payment that that Hunter Biden
received from foreign governments is
somehow illegal not [__] one they
can't prove it because there is no
evidence because it's not the truth it's
[__] lies and it's all lies so that
way m
gets to say next year when they go elect
a [__] criminal as their when they go
vote in the voting booth and they mark
on the ballot someone who has over a
hundred because he's gonna have over
aund felonies by the time we get the
next year I'm sure and he'll probably be
at on bail in five or six different
jurisdictions it's four now it might be
five or six then but when they Mark
Donald Trump's name on that ballot they
can say to them themselves oh Trump's a
criminal but Joe Biden's the same thing
that's that's whole
intention that's it and they failed in
that yesterday really is what they did
now they didn't fail in their messaging
because don't don't get it twisted folks
it's a cult you gotta understand it is a
cult the cult is gonna believe no matter
what and they're going to be believe the
lies no matter how big they get no
matter dumb they get no matter how easy
it is to prove that it's wrong but
here's the thing here's the optimism
here that I was telling you about
earlier this is like 12% of the country
yeah that's a large number of people but
they ain't got enough [__] to
outwork us in our democracy it just
ain't going to happen well let's listen
to Neil how he's he's super confused he
really he really thought it feels like
to me that Neil actually thought that
this was gonna something was gonna come
out of this what a [__] idiot Neil
kabo I want to put in perspective here
though and we are going to legally go
through all the details but James comr
the oversight committee chairman had
said that there would be presented a
mountain of evidence mountains against
Mr Biden it was referring to President
Biden but none of the expert Witnesses
today
presented yet any any proof for
impeachment now to be clear this was not
about impeachment this is about
launching an impeachment inquiry but it
is worth pointing out that none of the
witnesses today were fact witnesses that
means that none were involved in the
investigation into the alleged activity
in the first place what's more none of
the witnesses testified today of direct
knowledge of what Republicans have been
claiming about Joe Biden in other words
that this the way this was built up
where there's smoke there would be fire
again I'm not a lawyer and I'm going to
be talking to some darn Smart Ones in a
moment but where there's smoke today we
just got a lot more
smoke smoke straight up your ass Neil oh
my God they're blowing smoke straight up
your [__] ass ain't that something H
I wonder what it could be I wonder why I
wonder why Neil kabudo thinks this is
just smoke blowing out their ass and
there's no fire anywhere I wonder what
it could
be could it be that they're lying sacks
of
[__] of course that's exactly what it is
that's exactly what it is Republicans
are
trash and they only serve one
[__] one [__] only one
[__] and that's Trump and
because Trump is on the ropes Trump is
gonna go down Trump is in big
[__]
trouble and if they don't protect him no
one will and he knows that that's why he
made
sure that's why he made
sure that Kevin McCarthy was his
puppet and speaker so that he could do
everything he could in the House of
Representatives as an authoritarian to
run rough shot over this country let me
show you another clip from from
moscowitz here's a representative
moscowitz giving us some graphics these
are great graphics I don't know if he's
GNA put these out as memes or not but
they should be memed everywhere let's
watch but look let's let's go back at
some of the previous comments that my
colleagues have given so the chairman
and I have a slide the chairman goes on
Hannity right you guys all know Sean you
you you appear with him on Fox News all
the time right and Hannity asks a
softball question right this is a total
softball do you believe that this is now
officially the Joe Biden bribery
allegation and do you believe you will
be able to prove it the chairman should
have just said yes but nope he says hope
so because he doesn't have any evidence
couldn't say yes right next slide please
then we have then we have Senator
Grassley Grassley says what we all know
out loud we aren't interested in whether
or not the accusation against Vice
President Biden are accurate Chuck we
know we know you're not interested in in
the truth next slide please and then
Donald Trump you know he's giving it all
away we know he doesn't he likes to show
his cards he says I think had they not
done it to me perhaps you wouldn't have
it being done to them and this is going
to happen with indictments too so you
know Donald Trump the tough guy right he
what is he saying he's teaching the
lesson we all teach our kids right if
they do it to you go do it back you
can't help but love MTZ either can
you oh my God these people just rake
stepping all day long oh man just walk
straight into it um there's another
mosow
it's Graphics let me show you some more
Graphics that he had not only that he
got out Katie Porter's whiteboard
apparently let's watch put another way I
want to channel my inner Tim russer so
let me go to the board right and I don't
have Florida Florida but Donald Trump
impeachments oh how many impeachments we
got two there how many indictments we
got four how many for Biden z z Donald
Trump is right I'm he's sick of winning
he's just winning running away with it
and that's why we're here we're here
because of math that's what this is
about they can't save Donald Trump they
can't take away the two impeachments and
the four indictments but they can try to
put some numbers on the board for Joe
Biden but the problem is when you sling
mud you got to have mud and they just
don't have anything Mr chairman so look
I I I we get it we know why we're here
that's why they say the Biden family the
Biden's James Biden Joe Biden's dog
Commander but but not Joe Biden never
Joe Biden so when are you gonna have the
vote on impeachment Mr chairman what are
you scared of call the vote come on if
you all think there's so much evidence
we're here call the vote on impeachment
impeach him right now I dare you there
you go I'm telling you it's almost like
it's almost like there's some staffers
listening to this show too didn't you
get a little bit of didn't you get a
little bit of [__] them Vibe out of
mosit there at the very end I dare you I
[__] dare you do it [__] do it you
some [__] do it I dare you and mosit
and before that here's more MOS it's
great so look you know look we're all
appearing now in the world's worst acted
TV drama right it's been picked up for a
second season the real house Republic of
oversight you know perhaps the material
so bad due to the writer strike uh I I
mean how many Republicans Freedom caucus
members part of the chaos caucus have
said there's no evidence to impeach Joe
Biden uh and again of course we know
it's not about the evidence why here is
a list of all of the Articles of
impeachment that have been filed by my
colleagues some that are on this
committee when was the first article
filed it was filed in January of 21 two
weeks after January 6th so before we had
a single hearing before they went
through this Myriad of fishing they were
filing articles of impeachment Professor
Turley you said this doesn't rise to the
level of impeachment and you said they
shouldn't prejudge well here's a list
right here of every single member many
on this committee prejudging they're
filing articles of impeachment Co
Afghanistan Hunter Biden and they're all
one up each other in the Donald Trump
friend Olympics trying to get invited to
over at MGO I filed articles of
impeachment against mer Garland no I
filed Artic impeachment against KLA
Harris okay it's it is ridiculous but
this is what this is about let me here
go watch this board right so all other
presidents in the United States 50% of
the impeachments Donald Trump the other
50 Donald Trump has half of the
impeachments in American history that's
awesome you know what he's got 100% of
the indictments man 100% of all
indictment pres let me do it another way
I want to oh my God and then he goes to
the Katy Porter whiteboard I
can't I don't know I don't know if we
could get Crockett and moscowitz just to
play off each other that's not really
how time works in Congress like each
Congress person gets their own time
really honestly if they could just like
you know yield their time back and forth
Bam Bam and just play off each other
wouldn't that be [__] awesome oh my
God imagine how much democracy would get
done and how many Republicans would be
crushed in the meantime whoo
whoos oh my
God it's horrible all right here's
speaking of great Representatives here's
Frost here's Frost if you're looking for
the frost dip clip from yesterday here
we go we have one witness who has a lot
of questions Miss o Conor dubinsky one
witness who knows something about
accounting but has no real involvement
what's going on and Mr Turley stopping
here on his way to his next Fox News hit
this this is not a
serious oh did you see her face God damn
let's back it up watch her face oh my
God witness who knows something about
accounting but has no real involvement
what's going on and Mr Charley stopping
here on his way to his next Fox News hit
this this is not a serious inquiry
oh man representative Frost dunking him
in the [__] trash isn't he son of a
[__] they're jokes what do you want
what do you want other than to laugh at
these [__] this is serious
[__] [__] folks they're gonna shut
down our [__] government they're
going to shut down our [__]
government there's going to be military
personnel our border is going to be less
secure we're going to be less ready
there's going to be people not receiving
the payments that they're supposed to
receive throughout this country
and they're doing this [__] [__] and
we're not supposed to laugh at these
[__] wait wait for wait until three
or four weeks from now when Kevin
McCarthy is going to Joe Biden begging
him begging him to get Democrats to vote
for that [__] Senate bill I don't
know if you know that the Senate passed
the CR that hopefully the house will
take up I doubt they will they aren't
going to be able to get that bill to the
floor I doubt it and even if Kevin
McCarthy gets to the floor he's going to
have to go beg Joe Biden to get
Democrats to vote to pass that CR to
open the government and not get blamed
but they're still going to get
blamed so [__] them [__] them when
you're doing this type of [__] keep
going dummies keep it going you look
like fools and you're G to keep looking
like fools and we're going to point it
out that's what we're going to do that's
what we're going to do speaking of
pointing it out here's ktie Porter
and before I before I show this Katy
Porter clip this is a good spot where I
can talk about Senator Feinstein again
Senator Feinstein passed away this
morning age of 90 a lot of people are
sad about this she's a sen she's the
first one of the first women um to ever
be in politics really she's been around
for a long time but Senator
Feinstein passed away so that seat is
going to be open so Katie Porter is
going to be one of the ones that
probably Gavin Nome is going to consider
now I'll tell you my personal opinion is
this is who I want I want Katie Porter
to be the senator from California and
you're going to see why in this clip but
the main reason why is she's a [__]
woman and and Katie Porter's smart she
doesn't give a [__] and she'll go after
you and she'd be a damn good Senator
because really this this seat is going
to be a li almost a lifetime seat more
than likely but here is here is Katie
border going after Turley do you know
who made this statement and if so who
I don't I've made an impression along
those lines wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait okay let me back up let me
back up again this is why I want Katie
border to be the senator now a lot of
people want Adam schift Adam schift is
just as qualified might be just as good
or better of a senator might be I don't
[__] [__] who knows and barbal Lee same
same thing but how in the [__] can you
not get past the
snark when Katie reporters question
these dumb some [__] right am I right
or am I wrong we claiming my time this
quote is a
statement oh from now speaker Kevin
McCarthy Mr dubinsky do you know the
date of the house floor vote on this
impeachment
inquiry no I don't think there was a
house for vote Miss o Conor do you
remember any house vote I have not been
following that uh Professor Turley was
there a house vote on this impeachment
inquiry not that I know so every single
one of these some [__] were called in
for an impeachment in quiry and not one
of them have been paying attention what
the [__] the answer is no just say it
you [__] boxes it's no there's not been
a vote that's why you're sitting where
you're sitting you dumb [__]
Jesus Christ how in the [__] are we in
this weird weird ass timeline so this
house vote didn't happen there has not
been a house vote to move forward with
this impeachment inquiry so we haven't
followed what the speaker himself Mr
McCarthy has said is the process that we
should be following so that an
impeachment inquiry would have Merit or
legitimacy which is something that I
think all Americans on both sides of the
aisle should expect investigations or
inquiries like this to have I think
Americans should be able to expect that
the things we do in this body have Merit
or
legitimacy today by having this hearing
Republicans have changed their tune I
think I know why speaker McCarthy is
going back on his conviction his members
are demanding an impeachment but their
months and months of investigating our
president have not revealed yet any
evidence that he himself has committed
crimes but speaker McCarthy wants to
keep his job so he has set on delivering
an impeachment inquiry whether or not
there is any evidence and even if in his
own words that impeachment inquiry would
be devoid of any Merit or legitimacy Mr
dubinsky I have one final question what
is the title of this
heory title was basis for an impeachment
inquiry of President Joseph Biden but
according to speaker McCarthy there
isn't a legitimate or meritorious basis
yet for this hearing and oh my God again
this is one reason why I want Katie I
would love to see ktie Porter as United
States senator of California nothing
would nothing would please me more the
main reason why is because a woman is
leaving that seat I want a woman to take
that seat and I think Katie Porter is
just just a banger you has to bang her
and she would do a bang up job and boy
she would do it for a long long time
banging up these [__] Republicans in
the United States Senate because she
would take her whiteboard on the road
and go into the Senate chamber and
really hand it to him so and I I hope I
hope either one of the three Katie
Porter Anam shift or Barbara Lee they're
all qualified to beat United States
senators they're serious Congress
they're serious Congress people they
have serious Congressional staffs it
shows um that these people are serious
and that's probably the most important
part and it really is um the part that
is most important to our democracy is
that we have serious people that's why
when she does that she treats them so
unserious because they really are
unserious can you imagine having a
[__] Hearing in the United States
Congress calling witnesses to that
hearing right before the government's
shutting
down and those Witnesses having no
idea no idea of why they're there and
and the context of which they're there
are pretending at least get the [__] out
of here and you want us to treat you
seriously you don't want us to treat you
like a bunch of brain dead idiots okay
yeah okay good luck with that speaking
of brain dead idiots you guys know I
love this
um the the prophet you know what I mean
Julie green you've seen the the lady
that receives the emails from God you
remember
her oh my
this lady that receives emails from God
so she had Mike Flynn on her show she
had Eric Trump a while back we showed
that clip but this lady receives emails
from God and she reads them off you know
what I mean none of them come true I
don't know who God is and I don't know
who is [__] with her but I really
want to get in touch with that person
who thinks or who she thinks is emailing
her and who she thinks is God but listen
to Mike Flynn here this is wild ass [__]
Mike
Flynn if you're not aware of who Mike
Flynn was is was was he's crazy he's a q
in honor he probably is q but here's the
thing Mike Flynn was the National
Security adviser for Trump he's the one
that Trump had to fire because he lied
to the FBI about his Communications with
Russia but listen to what he says about
Julie green the email the god email lady
here that's one of the things that you
do so well and that's why I believe
you're one of them you're you're one of
like maybe two or three that I've met
who I so have I've come to so believe
that if prophets walked on the earth
2,000 years ago there's no reason why
they don't walk on the Earth today and I
firmly believe that they do and and
that's why I believe in you
and so not only does Julie green believe
that these emails are from God Mike
Flynn totally 100% believes that Julie
green is receiving emails from the
deity let's keep going it's hilarious uh
and I think that that's uh yeah that's a
that's a sentiment that's a feeling that
is an emotion and that's a feel that I
have that will not go away oh a feel
he's got a feeling like a like a like a
shiver down his leg ain't that
something H if you don't find the humor
in this I don't know what you're doing
you're doing it wrong but you know what
this is dangerous [__] this is dangerous
[__] you know how big of a a following
Mike in has and how many people believe
that guy's nonsense because Trump props
him
up and then he's going on this show and
telling this crazy [__] idiot that he
believe every [__] Mike Flynn cult
member out there because that's what
Mike Flyn is he's the lieutenant in the
cult he's a lieutenant in the
cult the Trump cult the Maga cult the
qanon section of the cult well part of
the Q andon section of the cult and now
he's giving her in these emails from God
so I want to get in touch with the
person who is emailing her who she
thinks is God I want to get my own
little quips in there in those emails
see if she'll read them out loud I don't
know these people are nuts they're
[__] Off Their Rockers they've lost
their [__] they are absolutely out to
lunch these religious [__]
listen to this guy this is a
superintendent Oklahoma listen that's
crazy some [__] and watch the lady in
the background now this audio is a
little RI here so bear with me it's not
my audio it's the audio of whatever
microphone he's talking to but watch
this lady in the background here when he
says the bigoted [__] he
says the other thing that I'm going to
bring to your attention today is an
issue we have with a radical woke
activist judge that is trying to
pressure one of our school districts
into going in and changing past birth
certificates I want to alert the board
we are seeing more and more of this
where he's not seeing more and more of
this a [__] lie they're not doing
this it's all [__] but this
[__] listen to where he goes
folks this is the
superintendent of all the schools he's
the state superintendent the director of
all the schools in the state of Oklahoma
and listen to the thing that is on his
mind about children this is [__] wild
stuff listen to this guy and but watch
the lady's reaction in the background
watch her reaction it's hilarious her
judges are acting way out of sounds we
see a lot of this coming from the Biden
Administration trying to force dictates
onto our states and onto our individual
schools do you see what she did there
reality is child's gender on their birth
certificate is their gender this they
can't these nais let me show you what
she did here right
there she gives him the bird but here's
the thing these nais these Nazis are
absolutely hyperfocused on children's
genitalia it's [__] wild stuff and
for the the the the Director of
Education they call it this they call
him the superintendent of the state for
educa the Department of Education there
in Oklahoma different states call him
different things but there in Oklahoma
he's the director of all the [__]
public school public schools not
religious schools public schools and
this guy can't get his mind off what
genitalia children have that's where
these [__] Nazis are at I'm telling
you it's [__] wild and weird Gab
Sanchez was just in the background but
he he must have not had his setup right
so he'll be joining us very soon uh
let's see if I've got another clip in
the meantime I wanted to save this
one I better save that one for Gabe the
backwards cowboy
hat you know what I'm he loves to bash
on Elon so we'll we'll wait till Gabe
gets here to absolutely Crush Elon oh
here we go I can play this clip this is
a short clip here's another Republican
talking about the government shutdown
and why why it is so important that he
keeps his salary during the government
shutdown listen Congressman will you
take pay if the government shuts down I
am honestly not sure how that works well
you still get money the members of
Congress get paid the minority leader
Mitch McConnell said so on the floor
yesterday so will you accept that pay I
okay so this guy is so so in tune to
Congress because I'm sure between all
his meetings of the Nazi the Nazi um
money donors that he has bought his seat
um he doesn't even know how his own pay
works but let's listen to see if he's
gonna give up his pay pay I will you
know I'm not independently wealthy oh
you're not and uh we are uh oh he's not
independently wealthy so he's gonna take
his paycheck you follow that so members
of Congress they can take their paycheck
if they want to they can give it up but
they can take their paycheck if they
want to this guy's going to take it
because he's not independently wealthy
this Brandon Williams of New York let's
listen to what he says about average
Americans that that rely on checks that
are going to come from the federal
government in the form of their paycheck
let's listen um like any other family
yeah I don't think you're G to find a
huge amount of sympathy um you know for
people that have been furloughed or
early retirement uh or laid off or their
pension going bankrupt uh um you know
you're not going to find a huge amount
of sympathy uh out there that's that's
I'm afraid that's just the reality so oh
well he doesn't have sympathy for other
people that need to be paid but he wants
his money you know what he's got a
family he's entitled to it I want my
rich white welfare I don't want you to
have your poor Brown welfare okay you
got it that is Mr Brandon Williams ID
ology here about how to get paid in a
government shutdown [__] this guy [__]
this guy I I'm telling you over and over
and over I'll tell you again and again
and again and again and again and again
the Republican party doesn't give a [__]
not one [__] about the American people
they're not Patriots they don't give a
[__] about our country frankly they
[__] hate America and they hate
Americans that's what they do they have
disdain for America
they don't like people who rely on I
don't know their labor to make a living
they don't like people who want their
fair share of pay when they trade their
labor for a living they really despise
all this stuff where the hell did he
go he he was here and then he was gone I
was gonna bring him in like and then he
was gone Gabe Sanchez is gonna join us
it's probably GNA be a a a fast if we
can to a fast bone head of the week uh
here on the Tony Michaels podcast on
Friday and we're going to try to get it
going here as soon as we possibly can um
so let's do this let's go to a break
when we come back Bon
head of the week don't go anywhere we'll
be right back right after
this we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds
this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babel Maga
Edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacist the first lesson began
with learning simple phrases and soon I
was putting those words and phrases into
a conversation each lesson takes about
10 to 15 minutes to complete and they're
all really different which keeps things
interesting the app is really smart it
actually keeps track of the words that
I'm struggling with I chose Babel magga
Edition because it's created by smart
white people like me and now I can't
wait to explore meet new friends and use
my new magga skills with my in-laws all
lives
matter jumping back into it this is the
Tony Michaels
podcast welcome welcome back to the show
it's
Friday
it is the second hour well we're into
the second hour here on Friday so we're
going to do flash round bone head of the
week gab Sanchez in his new and improved
set over there for what was that live is
joining us today he made it he made it
to bonehead of the week made it made it
that's awesome that's awesome uh let me
see if I can get these
um these uh these assets up here as ETS
assets so so who do we end up I I know
what we had on the poll but who did we
end up here oh I see okay I got okay um
I I figured I figured this one character
would make an yeah there's no yeah I was
like he's
he is is what what was it about that
event well we we'll get into it yeah
there's a lot there's a lot we'll get
into it um how how feeling today how's
everything going how'd your show go
yesterday what was that live is good
good yeah great you bash bashed a lot of
House Republicans yesterday I guess is
yeah I mean you know okay not really
hard that's well I know that's that's
what I've been doing all morning did you
know that hearing went for six hours
yeah they they literally subjected
themselves to that torture for six hours
they that incredible they went six I
mean we'll talk about it obviously well
let's play Let's Play The intro and then
we'll talk about that's
it oh no come on bro wait wait wait I'm
I'm getting there
[Music]
[Applause]
there bone end of the week you know
what's funny is I have the other window
up to put the Assets in so I play I
played the music over there and you
thought it was yeah and I thought I was
in I thought it was Bo huh an idiot wow
what an idiot people people like the
flutes man I know speaking of speaking
of idiots and Bon ends here's our bone
ends of the week the three committee
chairman who are who are instructed to
impeach Joe Biden or at least pretend to
impeach Joe Biden that's what they did
yesterday was in pretend to impeach Joe
Biden I mean you might say that these
are the three stooges it could be I mean
they really truly are the three JS James
Jim and Jason Triple J yeah yeah well
now yesterday Jason Smith isn't actually
on the oversight committee right so he's
not he wasn't in the hearing yesterday I
don't believe but he's the chairman the
thing that gave him the bonehead uh uh
of the week is his little press
conference that he gave the day before
the hearing so the day before yesterday
uh was the problem that Jason Smith had
is he no he's on the oversight hearing
is he is he okay so he was he was there
he made a I believe well I believe he
was there okay well if you can
definitely had this exchange I'll try to
see if I can find him the the thing that
I put him on the bone of the week was
for this press conference oh yes
wholeheartedly 100% it was this it was
this one right here you don't you don't
show up the day before the exam and
answer the questions about hey do you
have sources for the claims you're
making or the you know the statements
you've made on this exam of this
presentation and then they
go why do I have to answer that right
well here it is here it is watch Jason
Smith be a royal bonehead here and step
right in his own rake as it were
forunate that we see so many meetings
and so many phone calls uh that involved
uh around official activity that the
vice president has been participating in
and then big sums of Money Follows later
if he's president or the vice president
at that time where where's the wrong
doing he wasn't even a candidate for
president
he was a candidate
in a so apparently happened was apparent
what source are you
with I love I love how it matters I love
how it matters to Jason Smith what
source he's with he's like wait wait
wait are you mainstream media let tell
you guys about mainstream media
mainstream media is out to get us and
they think that we don't have the actual
evidence that we claim that we have I
mean I just want to remind people and
I've got a what was that that I'm
working on this because honestly this
what was that I don't have to do much
work in this one like it's all Democrats
[__] dragging Republicans I just add
some lines in between for context they
just Clips Just Clips this episode's
just to be clips clips clips I mean what
else are you going to do really I mean
can there's nothing else I can you drag
them better than they drugged them
yesterday I mean had you had Crockett
Lee AOC MTZ I was playing FRP Rasin all
like everyone came with their [__]
aame for this thing but what I find
hilarious is and something I want to
remind everyone is that James comr on
several occasions he was on Laura
Ingraham he was on Sean Hannity he was
on Newsmax when they were you remember
the audio tapes do you remember the
Biden audio tapes those 17 audio tapes
that allegedly allegedly
allegedly that Chuck Grassley put out
there uh put Joe Biden in a very
difficult position because it revealed
that he was actually they play those
yesterday did they play those yesterday
no they didn't play those because you
know what happened after those tapes
well those tapes were uh you know kind
of revealed to the
public the Republicans then said oh well
actually we don't know if these tapes
are real so like we don't know if they
actually exist so like we're not sure if
they're legitimate oh oh man it's almost
like we said that the day that they
announced that I I said these they're
probably not real give us the act
because didn't they release the
transcripts first well they released the
uh Grassley released an unredacted
version and then a redacted
version
and everyone after the fact after they
saw this they're like well where are the
tapes and then James comr on Newsmax
they literally asked point blank when
will we see the evidence like when will
you reveal the tapes to the public
because that is what we all want we want
the ability to see it for ourselves if
you're all about transparency and you
want freedom of speech and you want you
know un
uncensored uh type of democracy then why
don't you let the people have this stuff
if I was someone who was coming after
another person and I had this mountain
of evidence as comr said we' got
documents that go from here all the way
to the ceiling right if you have it then
show it put it online [__] give it to
give it to some sort of Wiki somewhere
put it online make it accessible and
then say look the proof is in the
pudding but they will never do that wait
wait wait when how did Ronda santis get
into
this when he heard when he heard the
statement the proof is in the pudding he
goes okay where where where's the
pudding where's the pudding he went dude
he he went three in and then three in
like where's the pudding you said
someone said pudding someone said
pudding oh my God speaking of Meatballs
uh Jim I don't report sex Grimes Jordan
ended up on Bon of the week I'm not
gonna actually play you a clip of Jim I
don't report sex crimes Jordan there's
plenty of Bon into Clips out there what
I'm gonna play you is Steve Bannon
cucking his ass this is [__]
fantastic Steve man was pissed off at
Jim Jord yesterday this was happening
during right because well because it was
it was like a 12h hour a 12h hour self
Dee for like 12 years it was crazy but
the funny part about it is moscit even
referenced Steve Bannon he's like dude I
just I just heard Steve banon on his
show talk about how you guys [__]
up during the W yeah he's like comr what
the hell are you doing here's here's a
little bit of Steve Bannon and his
co-host here I know I don't know who
this has let's watch followed it in its
entirety we're going to play your cold
open in the next hour give me your
thoughts well Steve I know you're
already live for four hours a day but I
think today really was Rock Bottom we've
hit the point where we need to bring
back War Room impeachment because our
House Republicans don't know what
they're doing at all this was Kevin
McCarthy's Hail Mary to try to convince
us that we can't shut down the
government frankly I think this makes
the case that we need to because they
need to reassess and Steve honestly the
best part in the middle of the hearing
do you know what the House GOP tweets
from their official Twitter account okay
I want you to know who who has some sort
of control over that who is it would it
be the would it be the guy with the two
JS in his name probably GMI don't report
sex crimes Jordan let's listen what they
tweet what they tweet Hunter Biden's
laptop is real that's the Tweet these
people are fundamentally
unserious so now so now anyone who says
Hunter B's left I told you like a week
ago I'm like where did they why did they
stop talking about laptop why did they
St the reason why they stopped talking
about the laptop is because it's not
real and now we're gonna find out it's
not real with the hunb lawsuit against
Rudy Giuliani well they can't I mean not
only so the laptop wasn't real the the
audio tapes weren't real the accusations
and the thing that that they also the
Democrats did a good job of yesterday
because they came prepared like they
[__] overprepared for it so that they
were like tight on their time tight with
their quips they had the jokes ready
they knew exactly what insults to throw
they probably I can only imagine what
the backup like alt lines would be you
know like they say the insult and she
you know Crockett's like oh looks like
you know found it in the [__] like I
can only imagine what other line she had
available to throw out there because I
can I can imagine that they went in
incredibly prepared with a bunch of
sources and a bunch of things to site
they fact check everything they called
out Byron Donald's like everything was
done perfectly how you show that the
Republicans don't know what they're
doing and I don't know if you heard
about this uh but there's this there's
this conspiracy
theory there is this conspiracy
theory that Kevin McCarthy allowed I
don't know if you heard this that Kevin
McCarthy allowed the inquiry to
happen as a
sabotage so that's what the rightwing is
saying so the rightwing because they're
going in they're like how did you guys
not know what you were doing how did you
come in so unprepared you guys have been
talking about this for years in the last
nine months all you've promised us as
constituents is that you were going to
come after Joe Biden Hunter Biden show
the corrupt family business and all
you've done so far is say they were
audio tapes well they don't really exist
there was a there was a laptop but it's
not really real there were these things
and those things and this and that
you've got margar Taylor green trying to
show porn it's [__] insane but when
you look at the whole thing they're like
well uh there's no there's no legitimate
way that they could have gone in
underprepared the only way that they
could have done it was if Kevin McCarthy
sabotaged them oh so that they would
then cuck and then not allow a shutdown
I I have to say that that's giving Kevin
McCarthy way too much credit no I know I
know like what Kevin MTH is The
Mastermind here are you kidding me are
you listening to what you're saying you
got to admit though I mean like when it
comes to creative you know they make up
anything won't they they they have the
most insane things it's it's like uh
recently I've seen a Resurgence of
people taking borax right and I'm like
what are you doing why are you doing you
idiots it's almost the same as Byron
Donald submitting fake evidence in this
trial and AOC calling him out
immediately let's watch that clip really
quick to uh I want to emphasize why
that's important earlier today one of
our colleagues a gentleman from Florida
presented up on this screen something
that looked appeared to be a screenshot
of a text message containing or
insinuating an explosive
allegation that
screenshot of what appeared to be a text
message was a fabricated
image it was a fabricated image I don't
know where came from I don't know if it
was the staff of the committee but it
was not the actual direct screenshot
from that phone and in fact I would like
to submit to the committee the actual
full
context from as from the zler a
affidavit number one exhibit 402 of the
full text of that exchange do I have
permission from the
chair
importantly what was brought out from
from that fabricated image excluded
critical context that changed the
underlying meaning and allegation that
was present okay so let me tell you the
allegation the allegation was is that
Hunter Biden was texting James Biden Joe
Biden's brother to get James Biden to
get Joe Biden to pay Hunter Biden which
is the exact opposite of what they're
saying they're saying Hunter Biden was
supposedly giving money to Joe Biden it
was supposed to is supposed to be going
through Hunter Biden it's exact opposite
of what they're saying this is like when
they when they showed that text message
and they're like look at this text
message and then everyone's like wait
this doesn't make any sense this photo
that's for Hunter Biden was taken after
they reported this text message being
sent and look well it was a it was a
dramatization well yeah it surely is a
drama right right right well here's the
thing Hunter Biden was actually asking
James Biden to go to Joe Biden to get
him to help him with alimony payments
because Hunter was out of money yeah
okay he was out of money he wasn't
trying to give Joe Biden more bribe
money he was out of it he didn't have
any he didn't money to pay his alimony
and Joe Biden being the good father he
was understanding sometimes you have to
have tough love didn't want to to pay
that alimony 400 he was gonna pay the
kids tuition and some other things but
in that email text chain with James
Biden Hunter Biden was trying to get
James Biden to campaign for Joe Biden to
help Hunter yeah it's crazy what happens
when when you don't splice and cut the
text message because what Byron Donalds
was he pulled up a a text message that
looked like it was sent in in an iPhone
and it had the blue bubble and it was
like look at this and then you know the
followup question to from Byron donals
to the people on on uh giving their
testimony under oath was well if you saw
this guys would you think that it
was that it was bad would you think that
this was a little uh concerning you know
and of course for the context they're
like well I from what we see here it
could
be and then AOC was like oh God I gotta
[__] show you okay because they
knew they knew what they were going to
do they were going to take the text
message that they had submitted into
evidence or done last minute and they're
like we need to figure out exactly what
they're going to say and what they're
going to show because if we don't then
it's going to we we need to the only way
to do it is to do it in real time and
I'm glad that the Democrats learn that
and did it so well is because if they
didn't then then the new right news
right new or right-wing media would been
able to run with this and say oh look
the Republicans won but really I mean
you had [__] Janine Piro on the five
goes you don't blow your wad on the
first day right you wait until the trial
and then you bring the person there you
don't show up the first day for an
inquiry bring up someone that you claim
has evidence and then when you asked
them Point Blank and cross and even Greg
Gutfeld was like you don't cross people
you don't allow people to cross-examine
your witness on the first
day what an idiot well speaking of
idiots and people who like to pay
pretend and get caught right away oh our
Alpha cuck Moy did he get cucked uh on
his own we on his own app on his own app
he got cucked yesterday Elon Musk I
don't know why he did this I have no
idea I don't know why the [__] you have
to actually so uh caretaker on uh on
Discord actually I didn't see I didn't
catch the clip until this morning but
they shared with me the mediasan
coverage of of uh of Elon mus no not not
not of this event but Elon Musk and
basically the the challenge that Elon
Musk was like our platform Twitter is
not a place where we have anti-Semitism
and racism and big I remember I remember
that CLI y so yeah so that happened last
night and it was a and I want to say
props to character for bringing it up to
me because maybe I'll do a what was that
on it um I mean it was a beautiful
takedown but um in in that moment you
you have El you well I mean it really
expose that but in this moment here
where Elon is on the on the southern
border you have to realize what Elon is
doing he is plating he is trying to uh
to instigate and bring all of the incels
all of the racists all of the people who
are xenophobic right to the fold to
broadcast a video of him showing people
at the border to 150 plus million people
now despite the fact that a lot of those
are Bots and Bots can't really interpret
you know a video like that when I looked
at it it only had like two million views
yeah and it's I mean it went it was it
it was basically the video version of
Ronda santis announcement there was a
bunch of technical issues Elon Musk sent
an email godam Elon Musk sent an email
to the company saying fix this please
please fix this right now and then he
made another video and the second video
is what I caught it on where he was like
oh we had some technical difficulties we
had a 15minute video at a conversation
one of those people who are on the
[__] border that representative
should have been there at the capital
but he went down to the border to show
how oh no IM this immigration is a real
problem all these illegals coming over
what what the [__] is law enforcement
meeting with with a guy who builds penis
rockets and and EVS on the border for
bunch of [__] it's a circle jerk dude
well you know yeah you know what's funny
is everyone's pointing out the fact in
this picture and there's one video where
he's adjusting this hat yeah he's got
this hat on backwards yeah I
mean if we're gonna talk about people
who are from this country okay of all
people to
criticize and try to demonize people who
are trying to migrants yeah who are you
to to demonize migrants who are looking
for Asylum for looking for safe haven
for looking you know to America as the
land of opportunity that we so promise
anyone who wants to come in so someone
could like work their way up be a
billionaire maybe buy a social media app
or something maybe it's crazy it's
innovate things like rockets and space
travel and EVs and let's let's keep ey
it's not it's not Elon Musk who's
innovating he's hiring people well right
I'm just saying the idea of it yes
exactly because that's what it all is is
ideas and lies but watch Elon Musk here
in his Joe Biden shade and his backwards
Texas Paul hat um On the Border trying
to explain to us why he this looks like
a hat that he purchased like when he
flew into Austin I doubt he Pur I I bet
someone gave this to him hey here's a
here's a hat cover up that shitty
haircut right let's watch El on here um
I'm at Eagle Pass just
arrived and um we're we're just going to
go around and and talk to the um
the major officials uh and law
enforcement whatnot that are here as and
just kind of iol the situation get a
sense for what's going on and and uh so
you can get the kind of like the real
story of on
here old citizen reporter Cowboy Elon
yeah I mean dude it's after this post
Elon Musk was like this is why we need
citizen journalism any citizen with the
camera in their hand can be a journalist
look again you don't need to call it
citizen journalism just call it
journalism right anyone can be a
journalist you could be a shitty
journalist like Elon Musk or you could
be a good journalist like uh like I I
don't even know countless others
countless others
like or any yeah anyone other than like
this guy who wears his cowboy hat on
backwards here's what I'll tell you as a
guy who wears a backwards hat a lot
because I'm I from the 90s that's where
I grew up and we wear our hats backwards
in the 90s and I still wear my hat
backwards I don't give a [__] what you
think if I look like I'm in junior high
I don't care I wear my [__] hat
backwards but there's one kind of hat
that you really shouldn't wear
backwards and it's a [__] cowboy hat
Elon that's why there it literally shows
you how to wear it there's like one
particular let me see if I can find this
one
tweet well that's why Elon why you're
looking for that that's why Elon ended
up as the alpha cck of bonee head this
week yeah here we go here's a here's a
perfect perfect indicator perfect
indicator to how you should wear a a
cowboy hat
okay even not even that it's not even
that it's like a fedora's very similar a
sombrero is very similar there were
indicators on the
hat that would show you oh this is the
front and this is the back there there's
him with the hat on backwards yeah yeeha
Cowboy look how this doesn't look like
it looks fake just it you know what it
looks like it looks like when you buy
one of those and I have a version of it
uh because I played for a little sketch
I was the uh the Hamburglar and you know
the Hamburglar it's got like that GAO
hat you know the black hat right it
looks like the same kind of felt
cardboard material that Elon Musk has on
his hat right now you're saying this
isn't a Justin is what you're a what's a
Justin you don't know that's a j Christ
that's a dud I don't wear cowboy hats
man that's a it's a western BR anyways
good wow all right but what right right
over your backwards cowboy
hat look if you look at that it's like
well this also doesn't make any sense
why would the front be bigger than the
back like unless you have an engorged
head I'm not sure why exactly you would
you would do that you know also it just
seems like not aerodynamic right like if
you're gonna have something you don't
want the full like the other thing too I
want to point out here the other thing I
want to point out here is does this look
like an alpha I mean really does this
look like does this it looks
like you seen man this doesn't look like
an Alpa right am I right that are uh
that are let me see if I can find them
but there are there are tweets that are
under this
idea of
um comparing his comparing his out
his beard his hat his whole thing to
products just failed products that he's
had like oh this is like the cybertruck
of uh neck beards this is the Cyber
truck of hats like just the ultimate the
ultimate insult against him on all of
the products that are complete well
that's because he not only is the alpha
cook he is really an insult to all of us
I mean really honestly So speaking of
insults and the king of insults why is
this guy the dishonorable mention today
did you put him on there for reason I
put him on there for his little [__]
anti-union [__] no you mean you mean
where he showed up at a non-union
facility and pay people to hold Union
and autow worker signs is that what
you're talking about yeah and not even
not even like Auto like I think the sign
said like unions for Trump or something
like that but but it's the idea that
that Trump as in an attempt in you know
failed desperate attempt to comat Joe
Biden showing up to an actual UAW picket
line on there
speaking standing with them alongside
them and say hey look I am pro-union to
which you have Republicans going ah Joe
Biden's the most pro-union president out
there that's great Union you can thank
unions for the wages you have the
benefits you have the safety regulations
in place to make sure that children
aren't [__] dying here's the signs
that we were talking about people aren't
working long hours and putting
themselves in toxic dangerous
environments I mean there was a comment
that I because I covered it on Monday
but there was a comment and I think it
was very very well do it was very well
done and simple it was like as my dad
said if it wasn't for unions we'd all
still be making $5 an hour and it's true
like without unions you wouldn't have
anyone that was that was fighting for
you you would have a company that
Republicans love because it's
capitalistic and they say oh well you
know big c big company good small man
bad and in the scenario if you didn't
have a union you wouldn't have anyone
that was defending you you wouldn't have
anyone that was that was the front lines
to fight for you so that when you came
into the job you didn't have to worry
about losing a finger or a limb or not
getting paid your due or your worth well
here here is two people one uh contrast
to the other you figure out which one is
fighting for unions that are fighting
for you and which ones thinks they're
lazy greedy pieces of trash let's see
what you think it's the same thing with
the Unions that's right they get their
little 5% they get another 2% they get
another 3% 4% then all of a sudden
they're making more money than the
people that own the company Wall Street
didn't build the country the middle
class built the
country you built the middle
class that's fact so let's keep going
you deserve what you've earned and
you've earned a hell a lot more than
getting paid
now so I I don't know maybe you can
decide which one is more Pro than the
other it's crazy because like you know
this really goes to this larger idea
that if you were to ask someone you know
even a a red-blooded [__] Republican
if you were to ask them straight up do
you believe that you should have access
to healthcare and that you shouldn't
have to pay for it they would most
likely be like oh that'd be great
especially if some of them live in
impoverished areas where health is an
issue or they live in an area where uh
there are certain things that were cut
by the EPA that have now caused health
issues I'm sure if you ask them hey
would you like free education so that
you didn't have to pay for for your
child I'm sure they would be like oh
that would be great I could use that
more you know more money to to put food
on a table I'm sure if you ask them hey
would you want better American sourced
us da Prime you know type of food would
you want that at a lower cost and I'm
sure they would say yeah I would love
that would you want to make sure that
far Farm Workers or or or uh Farm owners
didn't have to rely on government
subsidies because big corporations came
in and monopolized the market and Drew
the price down to now where the farmers
have to rely only on those subsidies and
only on the deals that they're willing
I'm sure they would yeah I would love
that so when you bring up this and
countless other things like even during
Co oh would you like more money to help
stabilize your income because $1600
isn't enough money money over a two-year
period I guarantee that every one of
these things they would be like oh yeah
if you ask them St up they like oh yeah
yeah and they wouldn't even question the
socialism aspect of it that Republicans
deem as terrible awful it's the
boogeyman well let's just see what the
union workers think about the two guys
that were just in the video Joe Biden or
Donald Trump let's see what let's just
see what they think about it Biden or
Trump Biden B
in 10 words or less why I am a woman
Trump's going to jail definitely Biden
not the
grifter B Biden Trump will Biden yeah I
hate Trump I think he's a stupid [__]
he's not nothing for the damn for us
he's for the companies Biden all the way
that's what Biden all the way B is I
call him Cool Hand B you want to hear
what I think about Trump [__] Trump
that's what I about [__] him [__] him
that's what he says [__] him [__] Trump
I mean who better who better to voice
their opinion than the very people who
are on the picket line the very people
who are who are sourcing the material
who are building the trinkets that you
and I buy every single day right whether
it's cars or it's a you know it's a an
assembly line or it's people on a farm
somewhere where picking something you
know this is something that really does
it matters because if no one is going to
fight for those rights that you have
assuming you have that position you work
in those conditions then when is someone
going to fight for you because it's
certainly not going to be Trump and it's
certainly not going to be these Fortune
500 companies they're only concerned
about how do I increase the profit
margin of my business to uh to make sure
that my shareholders are happy I'm gonna
cut costs by either cutting people or
cutting resources or trimming or cutting
Corners here and there you know making
sure that I have lobbyists that cut
regulations and then you find situations
after that where because of those cut
regulations we have now environmental
issues like what happened in East
Palestine like it's just it it's insane
to think that anyone would that anyone
would support Donald Trump or the
Republican party after knowing how their
governance actually creates a shittier
more harmful environment for both a
worker and also a
consumer well you know who else isn't
going to protect the American people you
know who else isn't going to this guy
the winner of Bon head of the week James
qanon comr boy he really stepped in it
yesterday big p of sh I mean it didn't
really it's that I used it I used hug
H bigly bigle bigle I used it I used the
the clip in my last uh what was that on
Lauren bobbert but this is another
moment where it's like ah man I might
have to reuse the Jurassic Park that's a
big pile of [__] clay it is well you
know speaking of big pile of [__]
there's like just tons of clips of James
comr yesterday there's one where he
doesn't even know if he has a clerk but
this one really this is like the very
beginning of the hearing and oh yeah
this set the stage and James comr here
believes from this clip that he's gonna
show the Democrats what for and by the
end of the six even like into the fourth
hour they lost Steve Bannon even on his
show as we showed earlier but let's
watch the Bon of the week Jim qanon comr
set the stage for what is about to come
I'd like to ask for recorded vote on
that Mr chairman this is on the subpoena
of the two key figures Rudy Giuliani and
love paros key figures for what but in
your theory about why President Biden
should be impeached I think there to be
an informative hearing for
you because oh we got informed yesterday
about how inept you are oh my God the
idea that he comes out here he's like oh
for what for what for the the [__]
reason that we're here today ex called
thing about this Hunter B laptops real
BMA BMA and and keep in mind they will
never say that Joe they always say the
hunter Biden family have have anyone
ever looked at the breakdown of the
Millions of dollars 75% of that went to
people Affiliated right not not the
family and a majority that went to
Hunter Biden because he had rolls on
these chairs right it's just well let's
listen to the bone in here let's let's
listen to him here if he can tell us
about you know how much evidence he's
going to provide it's going to go all
the way to the ceiling he says let's
listen we we were going to present
evidence what evidence there's no
evidence witnesses there no fact sit
back and let let the American people
hear the we all hear it the American
people now look you've gone over your
time we're going to have a we're going
to go by the rules here okay okay Moot
and I'm glad you brought the box of bank
statements if we had a box of all the
foreign money the bidens took it would
have reached to the ceiling yeah so
let's just
have no listen everybody's gonna get
five minutes I'm gonna present the
witnesses everyone's going to get a
chance five minutes I let the ranking
member go way over time in his opening
but we are going to abide by the five
minutes there's motion table on the a
motion on the floor
call a n debatable motion on the floor
wait for
it clerk will call the
rable yeah with a
clerk wouldn't have
aer's do I pay for a clerk we don't even
have a clerk he had a hearing and didn't
even have a clerk what a [__] bone
unprepared oh my God Jim comr you not
only are just a mix of boneheads with
the other Jays Jim I don't report sex
crimes Jordan and Jason Smith but you
are the bone of the week my friend and I
hope next week you keep going because so
so sweet Gabe Sanchez let's give Jim
qanon comr the B end of the week is
[Music]
[Applause]
due
[Music]
you know when you beat Jim Jordan that
[__] bad in a pole of how bad are
looked at both polls I was like I was
like oh [__] I was like God damn dude
give him a chance [__] I mean just hold
back for a minute guys I actually
believe that if we would put Marjorie
Taylor green on this B Jim comr still
would have been out front the whole time
the whole Mar Taylor green yesterday she
tried there were two moments and I and I
talked about him yesterday and dur my
what was that one was when she showed
the porn right and then she has some
weird Obsession and the second one then
I was like what the [__] is she talking
about she was like oh Democrats are the
the party of shutdown it's like [__] uh
do you know and I use that I use that in
a nice way uh do you know I don't I know
I don't
would who was president when a
government shutdown happened because I'm
pretty sure it wasn't Joe Biden right
I'm pretty sure it wasn't a Democrat it
was your daddy cult leader Donald Trump
well I appreciate Jim Jordan for all his
rake stepping that he did yesterday and
Jim man I'm not gonna take the shovel
out of your hand and no one else should
either keep going buddy keep digging
matter of fact I think we should all
pitch in and send Jim comr a backo so he
can be the bonehead of the week next
week and the week after this has been
don't go anywhere we got a few
announcements right after this bone head
of the
[Music]
[Applause]
week Bon head of the week you got a nice
set there for your new
show have you have you settled on it yet
you keep switching I know I'm not
settled on it yet I had to switch it
because when I go the other way I'm
toward the and more echy so I flipped it
to the for the wall right now I'm still
I'm still under under construction here
but I think I'm it again oh Jesus and I
got a bookshelf I'm gonna do a bookshelf
you know got some trinkets you know got
some chachis gotcha uh I got a bookshelf
I got kind like I got on yeah like I'm
gonna do a bookshelf over here you're
gonna have a dick Shadow though everyone
points I'll do I'll do a plant but I
won't have a dick Shadow from a dick
shadow not that I know who knows maybe
I'll just put a dildo back there for fun
could be could be so like more like a
Ted nent Vibe know sticking on the okay
I got you maybe maybe it'll you lower it
if you have it low enough you can
probably use it yeah who knows if I
really want to splurge maybe who whoa
easy on the dildo splurging talk saying
if I really want to splurge maybe what
I'll do is I'll do a remote or like
Bluetooth and I can have it oh okay you
know maybe when maybe when Republicans
speak just have it in the background
it's like an animated it's like an
animated yeah just as a you know just as
a character representation of the
Republican party you know if the
audience wants to catch Gabe Sanchez's
automated dildo automated Republican
dildo in the background you're gonna
want to join him after my show every
single Tuesday Wednesday and Thursday
he's got a brand new show what was that
live and also catch uh Gabe Sanchez what
was that as he does episodes that are
more detailed in in the situations where
we have these Bon heads that are running
around so make sure to go to imab
sanchez. that's imab sanchez. or is link
tree the links are down below visit his
show I'm glad that you guys are here I'm
glad that you made it here today for
bonehead of the week as we do every week
go ahead and subscribe to D Tony
Michaels podcast also don't forget to go
over to the Discord uh gab brought it up
earlier and I'll put the link in the
chat one more time here for the if you
want to if you want to go to the Discord
you want to have some fun over there the
chat party never stops it's where Gabe
was talking about his inspiration came
from for possibly a what was that now
you're going to want to check it out
You're Gonna Want to H communicate with
those folks over there room is like 1960
spatter room oh [__] you know his
original room I thought he was in his
grandma's basement
literally like a doily on the you
like work okay you know don't judge
don't judge a doily just depends just
depends um so make sure make sure you're
following us next week because we will
be here you're GNA do a Sunday thing
this for patreon right yeah yeah yeah I
I'll do yeah we we we'll be on Sunday
for patreon so visit visit all the links
down below you'll get to the patreon
page same time same place though next
week on Monday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific for two full hours have a great
weekend don't do anything I wouldn't do
surf up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow Tony on social media at
the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them
Murphy's mebn head ass
speaking